Allen Smith is a proud European he's a
member of the Scottish independence
Party and holds a seat in the European
Parliament Smith's fighting to keep
Scotland in the EU because even though
Britain voted to leave the EU many
Scottish voters chose to remain but as a
currently stands Scotland will have to
leave the EU along with the rest of
Britain government now he's working
feverishly to secure some sort of exit
from brexit
a week of meetings lie ahead of Allen
Smith he arrives at Strasburg Airport
the European Parliament chauffer service
is already waiting for him and two other
delegates who don't want to be filmed
holding their members of the UK
Independence Party the party that has
dedicated itself to getting Britain out
of the EU the journey passes in silence
until Smith's phone rings oh no it's the
cool meeting at 7:00 tonight there's
there's the chaos oh that's a quiet day
I've got something like 25 media bits
over the course of the week to explain
Scotland's position within all of this
under of course reaching out to our
friends in the UK to see what what we
can do as things are going forward it's
obvious that there was no plan then they
arrive at the European Parliament
Smith's been an EU parliamentarian for
thirteen years but never before did he
receive the kind of attention he does
now following his passionate appeal to
the EU Parliament he tweeted it was the
speech of my life millions watched it
online
I want my country to be internationalist
cooperative ecological fair European and
the people of Scotland along with the
people of Northern Ireland's and the
people of London and lots and lots of
people in Wales and England also voted
to remain within our family of Nations
we will need cool heads and warm hearts
but please remember this Scotland did
not let you down please I beg you
shut the head do not let's go plunge
down No
the speech actually I've been writing
for the last 13 years it came straight
from the heart but it was a clear
articulation of we want to remain part
of this and it didn't need a lot of
preparation because it didn't need a lot
of thought it was it was raw emotion it
was also pragmatic hard-headed politics
we want to remain within this family of
Nations let's find a way to make us do
that but that could prove tricky Smith
briefly stops by his office
with all the scheduled meetings he
doesn't really have time to check his
mail Smith wants to meet as many MEP s
as possible and win them over
like Rebecca harms who chairs the group
of green parties in the EU Parliament
but we've been talking to the Welsh to
Northern Ireland to London at London the
mayor's office also to Dublin I must say
and I think there will be a coalition of
interests which will meet its presence
felt as the UK finally comes to some
sort of negotiation but oh it's a mess
it's a mess
I feel always a bit in between two
positions I cannot decide so on the one
hand I think a long and pending
situation is not good for the UK and
also not good for the 27 on the other
hand this brexit vote cost real new
emotional move in the UK Europe so makes
me again think about how can we keep the
doors open issues that the EU Committee
on Constitutional Affairs will have to
address although Smith is not a member
he tweeted I might be seeing more of it
the debate on how to disentangle Britain
from the EU is becoming more and more
heated
many MVPs are pressuring Britain to
leave sooner rather than later
you should happen I have pity with a
Scottish because they didn't vote to
leave they wanted to remain but know
that the results are in we will see to
it that he you rules are enforced it's
time to start negotiations about
Britain's departure from the EU the
official EU position is this Britain
must invoke article 50 as soon as
possible and then begin negotiations but
that's exactly what Smith wants to avoid
the UK is not a country the UK's estate
made up of four countries and two of
those countries voted quite convincingly
to remain but if there was any
precipitous moves to close the door on
all of us no you would give precisely
the people that you don't want to help
precisely what they want the response to
Smith's appeal is lukewarm but he takes
it in his stride there's much more of a
nuts-and-bolts Committee about technical
matters discussing technical things in a
technical way so actually this is what
the European Parliament does well so
this is this is how we'll actually find
a solution it it's not just about the
theater it's about the hard work as well
Smith's hard work has already paid off
back home in his hometown of Edinburgh
he's celebrated like a hero by those in
support of the EU
showed the true passion of the 50% and
is really really good to have a voice
from the Scotland in the Brussels Smith
lives in ed Murrow with his partner for
years has been fighting for the rights
of gays and lesbians
he tweets so important these days to
protect equality Smith studied in France
and in Germany to him Europe is much
more than just a single market and he's
concerned by the rise of right-wing
populist throughout Europe like the UK
Independence Party and its leader Nigel
Farage I made a speech this week I'd
actually been planning for years and I
made a speech because I didn't want no
Jeff arrives to be the face of my
country after an unsuccessful
independence referendum two years ago
many Scots now want a second one but
Smith doesn't seem to want to get pinned
down on the issue
this is what I'm saying to everybody in
Brussels this look this is not about
independence we didn't want this we
didn't ask for this we voted against
this but it is about safeguarding as
much as we possibly can reception
Bingley
there's a lot of doors are open there's
a lot of people across the e you know do
know that Scotland wants something
different so that's good and we'll need
to see what happens it's going to be how
long you might have canceled holiday
back in the European Parliament
yet again Smith is told that the EU once
clarity over when Britain will leave
meanwhile Nigel Faraj is skipping the
session as usual
during the session Smith tweets shock
moving into granular discussion now
which is where we'll find solutions
outside Faraj declares his resignation
as the you curb leader but we start from
an extraordinary position that anything
is better than the current rotten deal
that we've got but I've had my time you
know everything in life runs its course
my time as leader of UK has run its
course
Smith is not surprised by ferocious
decision I think he's a very clever
politician and he knows exactly what
he's doing
the United Kingdom Independence Party is
not a professional group of people
they're not very clever half of them
they're not very hard-working I know
he's ditched them he's left them in the
less than in the dust and he is no the
independent voice personally of brexit
Smith has come to stand for all those
supporting the EU including those in his
own block of parties the Scottish
National Party is part of the Green
Alliance but here too Smith has to fight
after listening to an hour long debate
on environmental issues and the proposed
trade agreement between the EU and the
u.s. Smith runs out of patience you're
arguing about the color of the curtains
in the house while the roof is on fire
and the the the problems that my country
house right now exists in all of your
countries you have populist hsihu are
really really quick and clever to get
their information onto YouTube or
whatever else and say blame Brussels
you're right they do hate you and you're
arguing about whether you should accept
a quarter sale on TTIP yada-yada-yada
who cares
forgive me that the big picture is that
we could lose all this Smiths got his
backers firmly behind him but the
European Parliament isn't entirely on
his side yet so Smith gets his views
through to the media
he tweets manic day of interviews with
France Germany Latvia Italy Austria and
Bulgaria Smith would have much preferred
to have held these talks before the
brexit referendum now everything's just
so much more complicated he says
unipampa una cosa de Luz we Scots don't
delude ourselves into thinking we are
exceptional unlike the British
Scotland's a small country with a
population of just 5 million people but
we want to work multilaterally
internationally with others our
philosophy is profoundly European
particularly in the evening Northern
Irish bagpipers play in the European
Parliament Smith tweets it has never
been more important to understand how
Scotland in Europe works after this week
of talks Smith hasn't yet produced a
breakthrough but he has made one thing
abundantly clear not everyone in Britain
wants to leave the EU